so I am here at desmos calm which is an
online graphing calculator and the goal
of this video is to explore how shifts
in functions happen how do things shift
to the right or left or how do they
shift up and down and what we're going
to start off doing is just graph a plain
vanila function f of X is equal to x
squared that looks as we would expect it
to look but now let's think about how we
could shift it up or down well one
thought is well to shift it up we just
have to make the value of f of X higher
so we could add a value and that does
look like it shifted it up by one
whatever f of X was before we're now
adding 1 to it so it shifts the graph up
by 1 that's pretty intuitive if we
subtract 1 or actually let's subtract 3
notice it shifted it down the vertex was
right over here at 0 0 now it is at 0
negative 3 so it shifted it down and we
can set up a slider here to make that a
little bit clearer so if I just replace
this with if I just replace this with
the variable K then let me delete this
little thing here that little subscript
thing that happened then we can add a
slider K here and this is just allowing
us to set what K is equal to so here K
is equal to 1 so this is x squared plus
1 and notice we have shifted up and if
we increase the value of K notice how it
shifts the graph up and as we decrease
the value of K if K 0 we're back where
our vertex is right at the origin and
then as we decrease the value of K it
shifts our graph down and that's pretty
intuitive because we're adding or
subtracting that amount to x squared so
it changes we could say the y-value it
shifts it up or down but how do we shift
to the left or to the right so what's
interesting here is to shift to the left
or the right we can replace our X with
an X minus something so let's see how
that might work so I'm going to replace
our X with an X minus let's replace it
with an X minus 1 what do you think's
going to happen do you think that's
going to shift it 1 2
right or one to the left so let's just
put the one in well that's interesting
before our vertex was at 0-0 now our
vertex is at 1 0 so by replacing our X
with an X minus 1 we actually shifted
one to the right now why does that make
sense
well one way to think about it before we
put this X before we replaced our X with
an X minus 1 the vertex was when we were
squaring is 0 now in order to square 0
squaring 0 happens when X is equal to 1
when X is equal to 1 you do 1 minus 1
you get 0 and then that's when you are
squaring 0 so it makes sense that you
have a similar behavior of the graph at
the vertex now when x equals 1 as before
you had when x equals 0 and to see how
this can be generalized let's put
another variable here and let's add a
slider for H and then we can see that
when H is 0 and K is 0 our function is
really then just x squared and then if H
increases we are we're replacing our X
with X minus a larger value that's
shifting to the right and then as as H
decreases as it becomes negative
that's shifts to the left now right here
H is equal to negative 5 you typically
won't see X minus negative 5 you would
see that written as X plus 5 so if you
replace your X's with an X plus 5 that
actually shifts everything 5 units to
the left and of course we can shift both
of them together like this so here we're
shifting it up and then we are we could
get back to our Neutral horizontal shift
and then we can shift it to the right
like that and everything we did just now
is with the x squared function as our
core function but you could do it with
all sorts of functions you could do it
with an absolute value function let's do
it let's do absolutely that's always a
fun one so instead of squaring all this
business let's have an absolute value
here so I'm gonna put an absolute whoops
absolute value
and there you have it you can start at
let me make both of these variables
equal to zero so that would just be the
graph of f of X is equal to the absolute
value of x but let's say you wanted to
shift it so that this point right over
here that's at the origin is at the
point negative 5 negative 5 which is
right over there so what you would do is
you would replace your X with x plus 5
or you would make this H variable to
negative 5 right over here because
notice if you replace your H with a
negative 5 in the inside the absolute
value would have an X plus 5 and then if
you want to shift it down you just
reduce the value of K and if you want to
shift it down by 5 you reduce it by 5
and you could get something like that so
I encourage you go to desmos com try
this out for yourself and really play
around with these functions to give you
to give yourself an intuition of how
things and why things shift up or down
when you add a constant and why things
shift to the left of the right when you
replace your X's with an X - in this
case an X - H but it really could be X -
some type of a constant